>> From The Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
[ Pause ]
>> Yvonne Dooley: I want to welcome
you to The Library of Congress,
and thank you for coming out
for our program, Stand Out.
Our program is actually sponsored
by our Science Technology
Business Division,
and our Chief is here today, so we
are glad that he came out for this.
And it's also being offered in
collaboration with LC GLOBE,
our Library of Congress LGBT
Employees Group, our LCPA,
which is our Library of Congress
Professional Association,
along with our District of
Columbia Library Association,
DCLA, here in the D.C. area.
On that note, I would
like to introduce myself.
My name is Yvonne Dooley.
I am the Business Reference
Librarian
in the Business Reference Section
here at The Library of Congress.
And if you're here from
the Library I want to note
that today is the celebration
of National Library Workers Day,
so clap for you guys
and congratulations.
We also want to - I thought
that with the celebration
of National Library Week and our
Business Section here at the Library
that a program on, such as Dorie's,
on standing out in our profession
and in the workplace would
be an awesome program
to offer on this particular day.
So, without further ado, I
will introduce Ms. Dorie Clark.
She is the Author of Reinventing
You, Define Your Brand,
Imagine Your Future, and Stand Out,
How to Find Your Breakthrough Idea
and Build a Following Around It,
which was named the
number one leadership book
of 2015 by Ink Magazine.
A former Presidential
campaign spokeswoman,
she's frequently contributed to the
Harvard Business Review, Forbes,
and Entrepreneur and the
World Economic Forum Blog.
Recognized as a branding expert
by Associated Press, Fortune
and Ink Magazine, Clark is a
Marketing Strategy Consultant
and speaker for clients,
including Google, Microsoft,
Yale University, Fidelity
and World Bank.
She is Adjunct Professor
of Business Administration
at Duke University's Fuqua School
of Business and a Visiting Professor
for IE Business School in Madrid.
She has guest lectured at
Harvard Business School,
the Harvard Kennedy School, Stanford
University's Graduate School
of Business, the Wharton School,
the MIT Sloan School
of Management and more.
She is a frequent guest on MSNBC
and appears in worldwide media,
including NPR, the Wall
Street Journal and the BBC.
We are honored and so excited
to have Dorie Clark here today.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Dorie Clark: Thank
you so much, Yvonne.
All right, I'm used to having
clip-on mikes and being able
to wander around a little bit, so
I'm going to contain my impulses
and stand here in front of you
because they're recording
this session here,
but thanks so much for coming out.
Today, we're going to be talking
a little bit, as Yvonne indicated,
about how to stand out at work.
I mean the world that we live
in today is a lot like this.
In fact, this was probably your
metro commute this morning.
We live in a world where literally
in the past minute that Yvonne was
up on stage doing the
introduction, when I wrote Stand
Out the statistic then
it was 100 hours
of YouTube video was
uploaded every minute.
That is now obsolete, its 300 hours
of YouTube video is
uploaded every single minute.
We are in an era where even if
we wanted to, even if we tried
to consume all the information that
is out there it's a losing battle
and we're falling farther
and farther behind every day.
We can't do it.
And the problem with that
professionally for all of us is
that it's not just us that is
feeling that burden, everyone is.
The average professional gets
about 100 e-mails per day.
This is a number that is increasing
at a compounded rate
of 15% per year.
If it's not unsustainable now,
it is very rapidly becoming so.
And with all of these obligations,
these meetings, these e-mails,
these things that we're supposed
to read, the tweets we're supposed
to respond to, what
gets left behind is
that other people are not
really able to tune in and pay
that close attention to
you and to who you are
and to what you're doing.
Even your boss, even the people
who are theoretically responsible
for watching out for you and your
career arc oftentimes just don't
have the bandwidth to do it.
And, consequently, unless we want
to live our professional lives
essentially buffeted by fate
and just ending up where we happen
to land, we need to somehow begin
to start taking control of
our brand, of our narrative,
of how we are known by others
so that our true talents
can actually be heard
and understood and appreciated.
Otherwise, if we don't do it,
frankly, no one else will.
Now I fully recognize that
there are some challenges
and perhaps some resistance
to the phrase personal brand,
and so let me just rewind for a
minute and take a step back to talk
about where it comes from.
This is actually the
genesis right here,
this is a 1997 fast
company cover story.
It was written by a guy named Tom
Peters, who was known in the 1980s
as one of the original
management gurus.
He wrote a bestselling book
called In Search of Excellence
that was very popular in the '80s,
it sold more than two
million copies.
But 15 years after that
he wrote this cover story,
The Brand Called You.
And you'll note it
is not an accident
that it has the Tide
colors and logo.
The idea, and some people loved
it and some people hated it,
was is it true, should
we think about it,
that people have brands the way
that a detergent is a brand?
What are we to make of that?
And a lot of people get sort
of offended by that concept
because they say, well, you know
what, I'm a lot more than a soap
or a cereal or a detergent, I am
a complex and unique individual
and I don't want to have to resort
to selling myself in this way.
And so when they think if personal
brand this is what they think about.
But I want to posit something
slightly different to you,
which is that even though
personal brand is a charm
that was invented fairly recently,
you know, 19 years ago now,
what that phrase is referring
to, what it is talking
about is something that has
existed not for 20 years,
but from the beginning of time.
Personal brands is really just
a synonym for your reputation,
that is what we are talking about.
And if we frame it that
way it begins to put it
into a little bit more
contextual clarity.
You wouldn't really hear
a professional say, well,
I don't care what my
reputation is or why do I have
to have a reputation, the way that
they might about a personal brand.
Because when you get down
to it your reputation
in a lot of ways is all there is.
How, if you lose a job how are
you going to find another one?
If you want to move into a different
career, you want to get promoted,
how are you going to make
sure that you're the person
that gets chosen for that?
Ideally it's because you have a
reputation that speaks for you.
Ideally it's that people think
of you the way you would
like to be thought of.
You can't opt out of having a
reputation or personal brand.
People think something about you.
The question is what do
they think and does it match
up with what you would wish?
And so what I wanted to talk to
you about today is this process,
which for me actually
was a very personal one.
I started to think
about personal brand,
to learn about personal brand
now fifteenish years ago.
I started my career as a newspaper
reporter, and I have this cover here
because this I saved probably
about 20 of these in my attic.
This was the very first cover story
that I ever had for my newspaper.
And at the time we, you know,
I was a Political Reporter,
it was a newspaper that had
a little bit of politics,
a little bit of everything.
In fact, you will note at the top
here we covered some truly important
issues here.
I don't know if you could
see that, In Sync vs. Hanson,
very critical at the time.
[laughter] But I love
my job as a Reporter,
but unfortunately I was part
of the first wave of layoffs.
Now this today is not too unusual.
Actually, literally, just two weeks
ago I looked up the statistic,
I needed it for a paper
I was writing.
I looked up the statistic and would
you believe this is the number
from the American Society of
Newspaper Editors from 2000
to last year, 42% of American
journalists lost their jobs.
That's decimation of a profession.
But I had the good fortune, you
could say, maybe the bad fortune
of being one of the earliest
people to be in that wave.
I lost my job in 2001, and
I wanted to stay a reporter,
but to be honest I couldn't,
there weren't any jobs available.
And so I had to reinvent
myself, and I feel fortunate
that in the intervening
years I've been able
to do a lot of cool things.
I went from reporting on
politics to working in politics,
perhaps some of the people
here in the crowd do the same,
but I was a Press Secretary
on a Gubernatorial Campaign,
I was the Spokesperson on
a Presidential Campaign.
You'll note I never moved to
Washington because we lost.
[laughter] But, you know, I tried.
I ran a nonprofit for
a couple of years.
And eventually about a decade ago
I started doing what I'm doing now,
consulting, writing and
speaking and teaching.
But what I learned through
all of those reinventions was
that when I would talk to
people that I knew, you know,
I'd run into somebody that
I hadn't seen for awhile,
and inevitably they'd be glad to
see me, they'd be happy to catch up,
but they would ask me about the job
that I had had like three jobs ago.
They were not keeping
up with what I did.
And it was pretty dramatic
at the time
because I was changing
careers pretty frequently.
But something I realized is
that even if your changes
and transitions are less
dramatic, even if you've just been
at the same company but
you've been promoted
or you shifted functional roles
or even if you have stayed
in the same position over the period
of a few years you have
been learning and growing.
You have been experimenting
and doing new things.
You've been gaining new skills.
And the truth is other people
oftentimes are blind to that,
their perceptions of
us are stuck in time.
They are fossilized in amber.
And unless we somehow break
through and get them to notice
and to be aware of the changes
that we have been through
and what we have been learning and
where we are going now they're going
to think of us in that old way and
it means that we will not be top
of mind for the kind of
opportunities that we want now.
So how do we solve that puzzle?
How do we break through
that conundrum?
I'd like to talk to you today
about a three-step process,
which I learned about in the course
of writing my book, Reinventing You,
which really sprung from
initially the idea came
from my own experiences
reinventing myself,
but in writing the book I
interviewed dozens and dozens
of successful professionals who
had made these transitions to try
to understand what made it work
for them, what enabled them
to be successful, so that
hopefully we could get some common
characteristics and begin to carve
out a bit of a roadmap for people.
What I realized is that
fundamentally standing out at work,
reinventing yourself to the
place that you want to go
so that you can have
the career that you want
to have is a three-step process.
First, discovering
your brand because,
as we said, no one is a tabula rasa.
Second is creating your
brand, proactively setting
out what you want to be and
how you want to be known.
And, third, living your brand,
manifesting it on a
day-to-day basis.
So let's start from the beginning,
let's talk about how
we discover our brand.
One of the things that I suggest
in Reinventing You is something
called the three-word exercise,
and the reason that I do this is
that what I discovered in talking
with many professionals
and interviewing a lot
of executive coaches, people that
work with the creme de la creme,
you know, of course we
all have blind spots,
of course there are things
that we don't really recognize
about ourselves, but
there's something
that is even a bit more
profound than that.
Because the truth is by and large
we probably have a decent sense
of who we are, maybe how
we're seen by other people.
There could be exceptions,
but we have an okay sense.
But there's one piece that even
the smartest among us have real
difficulty with, and that is
knowing what it is about us
that is most unique or most
distinctive in the eyes
of other people because the truth
is we know ourselves too well.
Everything about us is normal to us.
You could read a book a day,
you could blitz through a book
in an hour and you'd never know
that was abnormal until you talked
to other people and they said, whoa,
you read that fast,
that's incredible.
And it's like it for almost
any other trait that we have.
We don't know what is different
or unique or exceptional except
when other people shine a light
on it and point it out to us,
which means that oftentimes
we're really missing the boat
when it comes to understanding
our strengths.
And so this activity that I
suggest, it takes two minutes,
it is not a hard thing
to ask other people.
Basically, what it entails is
over the course of the next week
or so ask about let's say half a
dozen people, friends, colleagues,
people who know you decently well.
I mean ask them this question,
if you had to describe me
in only three words
what would they be?
It's pretty simple, pretty fast,
it takes them a minute to answer,
and they should in fact answer
off the top of their head.
But what becomes telling about it
is by the time you get to the third,
the fourth, the fifth person
I guarantee you are going
to see patterns in what they are
saying and you'll begin to get more
of an understanding of
what other people see
as being uniquely different,
uniquely meaningful about you,
begins to give you some clues about
strengths that you can leverage.
But I also want to point out your
strengths are an important building
block, but it's not the whole game.
This is a woman that I profile in
Reinventing You named Libby Wagner,
and I loved telling Libby's story
in the book because oftentimes
when we hear reinvention
stories there's kind of a way
that they go typically in
the American psyche, right?
And the way that a story
about reinvention typically
goes is you have someone
who is this hard charging
professional, you know,
they're a management
consultant, let's say,
and they really do some
soul-searching and they say,
all right, I'm going to do
what I am passionate about
and they go off and
they become a poet.
And we tell the story, and we
say, oh, that's so amazing,
they found what they
were meant to do,
they lived the dream
and we celebrate that.
And that is worth celebrating,
that's a great thing,
we should all be doing things
we are passionate about.
But what I liked about Libby's
story is that that story,
the archetypal one,
it's not the only story.
Libby was a poet, she had an MFA,
she was a University Professor,
she published three books of poetry.
She was established,
she was successful.
She decided to give it
all up, quit her job,
and she became a Management
Consultant.
[laughter] And to tell you the truth
that's actually even harder to do.
We can understand why a Management
Consultant might want to be a poet,
but no one understood
why Libby wanted
to become a Management Consultant.
But she was interested
in making change,
and she thought an organization
is a place you can really do it.
But she was worried, she thought
that no one would take her seriously
if they knew that she was a poet,
that that was her training
and her background.
So her solution to it was
she didn't tell anyone,
she literally kept it a secret
for the first few years
she was in business.
She did not talk about
her background, at all,
and she told me she basically
lived in fear of discovery.
But slowly over time she began to
realize that nobody cared too much,
nobody was badgering her, asking,
well, where did you get your MBA?
What they cared about was results,
and she was getting
results for people.
And a little more time passed and
she began to realize something else,
which is that even though it
was very true that the people
who had MBAs and had
traditional training had things
that Libby didn't, she
had things they didn't.
She began to realize that if you
are a corporate CEO and, let's say,
you have some sensitive
communication that you want to get
across well, thoughtfully,
effectively to your staff,
to your customers, to
your stakeholders, maybe,
just maybe the person
you actually want to have
on your side is the person who has
spent a lifetime immersing herself
in language and who
has trained for years
to understand the nuance of words.
And so she slowly began
to come out as a poet,
she would tell a few people
at first and then a few more.
Eventually, she started an
e-mail newsletter called The
Boardroom Poet.
Eventually, she started to
have workshops about language
and literature and business
and how they all fit together,
and she began to realize that what
in her mind had been
her biggest weakness,
the thing she was most
afraid of having discovered,
the fact that she had trained
as a poet actually
could become a strength
and a competitive advantage.
So when we're discovering
us, when we are thinking
about who we are now, what
our current brand is it pays
to understand our strengths,
but it also pays to think
about our weaknesses because those
may be like Libby our strengths
in disguise if we frame
it the right way and begin
to understand it in that light.
But, of course, that's just the
first part, discovering our brand.
What comes next is creating
it, proactively thinking
about who we want to be, how
we want to be known to others.
And so I wanted to share
a few stories with you.
This is a gentleman
named Michael Lecky.
Michael is someone that I profiled
in my most recent book, Stand Out.
And I was interested in
his story because in a lot
of ways it's a situation
that many of us face.
Michael was an executive in
a large research company,
he was a Vice President of Human
Resources, and he had responsibility
for a lot of different things
related to talent development.
He began to become really
interested in coaching and training.
Now this was something that was
kind of related to his job duties,
but it wasn't part of his
official job description.
He was certainly not responsible
for getting good at coaching people,
that was not really
something that he needed
to do, but it fascinated him.
He was interested in it, he
wanted to learn more about it.
And so his company had hired an
outside consultant that they brought
in to help with coaching,
and Michael took his course,
thought it was really great.
And so because he started with
a spark of interest he decided
to follow it up and
see where it led.
So he reached out to the
consultant and he said, hey,
the next time you're offering this
could I help you, could I assist?
And he started in small
ways, you know,
you can start by helping people
set up or break down or clean up,
you can start by helping
people make handouts
or lead discussion groups at tables.
But he volunteered to assist,
and before too long he started
to make himself indispensable,
he was pretty helpful.
And so he began to co-lead the
seminars and over time he got better
and better, and he eventually
began leading them himself.
Now what happened inside his company
is that before too long he began
to really develop a reputation as
the person inside his organization
who knew about coaching
and training.
He didn't start out that
way, he didn't start
out with any more knowledge than
anyone else, but he had an interest
and a willingness to learn.
And what he told me when I
interviewed him for Stand Out is
that if you are humble and
recognize where you're coming from,
you can't immediately start out
and say, oh, I'm the expert,
but if you're clear about what
you know and what you don't know
and you're willing to
share that knowledge
with others along the way
they're going to be appreciative
and they're going to start to
seek you out because you're going
to become a big fish
in a small pond.
You don't have to know the most
about coaching and training
in the world, but if you
know more than the people
around you you make
yourself an invaluable
and indispensable resource.
It doesn't take a lot to
develop and expert reputation,
just a little focus, just a little
humility, just a little willingness
to tell other people and help
them along with you as you learn.
One of the other pieces that
becomes critical as we think
about how we get known for the brand
that we want, how to begin spreading
that inside and outside
our organizations,
is the circle of people
that you have around you.
This is a woman that I profile
in Stand Out named Cary Anderson.
And I've known Cary
for a number of years,
and one day she told
me something that was
so unusual it just
captured my attention,
and I thought I have
to tell this story.
And here's what it was.
A lot of people have mastermind
groups, you could call them,
personal Boards of Directors.
This is a concept that goes
back 80 plus years to the world
of Napoleon Hill, you know,
little groups of people
that get together regularly to
hold each other accountable,
talk about their businesses,
et cetera.
That's, you know, it's a cool thing,
but it's not an uncommon thing.
So Cary has a couple of those,
but the part that was amazingly
uncommon is she told me
that one group that she's been
meeting with was formed in 1989
and the other in 1994 and they have
been meeting every single month
since then, now for more than
20 years and more than 25 years.
she told me that the people in
these groups with her outside
of her immediate family are
the people that know her best
in the entire world
and that participation
in the group has become for
her the defining characteristic
of her professional life because
they are the people that know her
so well, when they give her
feedback, when they give her ideas,
when they push back
on her a little bit,
she knows that she can trust it
implicitly because they know her
so well and they have no agenda,
they have her best interests
at heart, which is something
that perhaps too often
in our modern life we lack.
Now what Cary's story bring sup for
me is this, when I talk to groups
of professionals I'll ask
them sometimes, you know,
who do you spend time with?
Who are the people that
you surround yourself with,
the people that you have lunches
and meetings and coffee with?
And oftentimes what I hear is, well,
it's the people who e-mailed me
and asked or it's the people
that I happen to sit next to,
it's the people that I happen
to be working on a project with.
If our professional lives
are defined by the people
that we connect with, why so
often do we leave that to chance?
We need to start getting
deliberate about who we want
to surround ourselves with, who
we want to be learning from.
And so I will challenge
you, as you go home today,
go back to your desks, to ask
yourself who are the people,
the three or five or seven people in
your life that you respect the most,
that you want most to learn from,
the people whose skills you wish
that you could be more like?
How can you arrange it proactively
to spend more time
with those people?
We learn through osmosis,
we learn through presence.
How can we change our behavior
just a little bit so that we can be
around the people who bring
out the best in ourselves?
Because the truth is
those are the people
who can become your
brand ambassadors,
the people who can give you the
feedback you need to take your ideas
to the next level, and
the people who inside
and outside your organization
can represent you to other people
and help you get the opportunities
that are dearest to your goals.
Now in this professional
world that we live
in what we're fundamentally
known for is our ideas,
and this can be a little
bit tricky sometimes
because ideas are ineffable, right?
How do we know if somebody's
ideas are good?
We have to share them.
We have to find ways of expressing
them and we have to really think
about how we can start prompting
ourselves to think differently
so that the ideas that we generate
are not just the same thing
that everyone else is doing.
You know, in a global networked
world the world doesn't need more
of the same, the world needs
people who are suggesting things
that other people haven't
seen or thought of yet.
But the question is how do we
put ourselves into that state?
How do we make that
more likely to happen?
And so I wanted to share with
you a story about someone
who actually is a local,
at least originally.
Her name is Rose Schuman
[Assumed Spelling] and she grew
up in the suburbs of Maryland.
Now up until when she was about
18 years old she had a pretty
traditional upbringing
in suburban Maryland,
but when she was 18 she took
a family trip to Nicaragua,
which is where her
stepmother was from,
to go visit the stepmother's family.
And that was something that
changed the course of her life.
It was shortly after the end
of the Contra War in Nicaragua,
and when she went there the
country was in disarray.
There was one functioning
streetlight in the entire country.
The systems, the institutions that
she had taken for granted growing
up 20 miles from here
were nowhere to be found.
And that was when she decided
she wanted to devote her life
to development work,
and that's what she did.
She went to school for
it and she graduated.
Took a job with an NGO.
And so a few years later she found
herself one day walking around town,
wandering around, and she
was thinking about a puzzle,
a problem that had occupied
her for years and, in fact,
it had occupied a lot of people
for years, which was the question
of how can we harness
the power of the internet
for the world's poorest people?
Now there had been a lot of
reasonably good solutions to that.
Many of you may, for instance,
have heard of the one
laptop per child initiative,
pretty good idea, right?
Cheap laptops, give them
to people, it's great,
but that's not still
a perfect solution,
particularly if we're talking about
the poorest people in the world.
Because the truth is the
laptops might be cheap,
but they're still a little
pricey, costs money to make them.
If you're giving them to someone
the people who receive them have
to have a safe place
to store a laptop,
which is not necessarily true
for the world's poorest people.
You have to assume if you give
them the laptop and want them
to access the internet
they have to be literate,
which we cannot always
take for granted
with the world's poorest people.
And even more to the point they
have to be literate in a language
that is widespread on the internet,
and if we take that to the extreme
of the poorest one billion people
that is almost never the case.
So how do you bring the power
of the internet to them?
Well, one day Rose was walking
around and she noticed something,
she noticed something that she
had seen a million times before
and you probably have seen
a million times before,
maybe even this morning on your
commute, which is a call box
like you'd find at
a transit station.
You push a button, talk to
somebody on the other end,
they answer your question.
And she realized if you
could put call boxes
in the world's poorest places
people wouldn't even need
to understand the concept of
the internet to take advantage
of the power of the internet.
And so, thus, was launched
Question Box.
She told me that she spent the
next four hours feverishly writing
in her journal coming up with
the idea, sketching it out,
and she spent the next decade of
her life working to implement it.
Today Question Box operates in India
and in many countries in Africa,
and it literally is a call box
that is placed in villages,
people can go up, push a button and
they are connected on the other end
of the line to a bilingual
operator in a centralized location
who will Google the answer to
whatever question they have.
And, in fact, the recent
Ebola epidemic
in Liberia Question Box became a
critical tool for the people there
because most of the international
aid workers had been evacuated
and one of the few ways that people
in remote villages could get
accurate information about Ebola
and preventing its spread was
through the use of the Question Box.
I tell you this story because
when it comes to being known
for our ideas, which is
fundamentally as a knowledge worker,
as a professional today, one of
the best things that we can do
for our brand, for our
reputation, so much of it starts
with doing what other people
are not, which is noticing.
Instead of being glued with our
heads down we need to notice what's
around us and make connections.
And one final thought on
creating ideas and connecting,
sometimes when I talk
about developing ideas,
being known for your ideas, I
hear from people and they say, oh,
that's great, that's
wonderful, but I can't do that,
I don't have any brilliant ideas,
maybe other people do, I don't.
And that brings me
to Daniel Goleman.
Some of you guys may
be familiar with him,
you're almost certainly
familiar with his work.
Daniel Goleman is an Author, who is
the bestselling Author of the book,
Emotional Intelligence, which was
a bestseller literally for years,
spent years atop the New York
Times Bestseller List in the 1990s.
The Harvard Business Review called
Emotional intelligence the most
important management
insight of the decade.
Now emotional intelligence, of
course, you're probably familiar
with it, it is the idea
that IQ is not everything,
it's not just about your
intellectual horsepower,
it's about how you
behave in the world,
how you relate to other people.
That might, in fact,
be far more predictive
of your ultimate success
personally and professionally.
Today that's well understood,
well accepted,
but when Daniel Goleman
wrote his book it was not IQ,
for the past 50 years had
been the be all and end all
of how people measured and predicted
one's success later in life.
I didn't know a lot
about Daniel Goleman
when I started writing Stand
Out, but I was interested.
I thought where this idea
has become so seminal,
where did it come from,
how did he develop it?
And because I hadn't given it a lot
of thought, what I assumed, frankly,
was I assumed he was a researcher
and that he had written a
book about his research.
But I looked into it
and I discovered
that was actually not true.
Daniel Goleman was a reporter,
he was a science reporter,
and he read a journal
article about the study
that showed emotional
intelligence was so critical.
And he said this is important.
People need to know about this,
but if he had not popularized it,
if he had not taken
it and brought it
to the mainstream probably it would
have remained a relatively obscure
phenomenon that only a few
researchers really knew about.
When I was writing Stand Out I
interviewed a couple of gentlemen
who are behind a biennial ranking
of the world's greatest management
thinkers, it's called Thinkers 50.
And I asked them, you
know, what does make
for a great management thinker?
And they told me something
fascinating, their perspective,
they said, was that when
it comes to a truly great,
truly innovative business thinker
originality they said is overrated.
Instead, some of the greatest
thinkers are synthesizers,
they're people who spot great ideas,
underappreciated ideas that need
to be heard and they
help them become heard,
like Daniel Goleman did.
If you don't feel like you have
any great earthshattering ideas,
that's okay.
What you need to have is the ability
to notice, like Rose Schuman did,
the ability to talent spot,
not just people but ideas,
the way that Daniel Goleman did.
If you find ideas that
deserve to be heard,
that deserve to have a
wider spread and you're able
to help get them heard that's one
of the most valuable functions
you can serve and it's one
of the best ways that you can make
a mark and become known inside
and outside your organization
for your ideas.
Now, finally, it comes
to living your brand
because the truth is sometimes I'll
talk to people about their brands,
about personal branding in general,
and they'll say, oh, yeah, yeah,
yeah, your personal brand,
that's like your elevator pitch.
[laughter] And kind of, yeah,
your elevator pitch, you know,
what the short little thing
that you say about yourself,
that's a piece of it for sure.
What do you say about
yourself when people say, so,
who are you, what do you do?
That's important, but the
truth is if we think about it,
if we think about how we
determine what we think
about other people
it's not just based
on what they tell us
about themselves, right?
That's the smallest piece of it.
What we think about
other people comes
from how they are in the world.
It's about how they act, what they
do, how they live their lives,
how they relate to others, how
they treat us, that's their brand.
Yeah, it's a little bit what
they say, but by no means is
that the end of the story.
And so the real challenge, the real
opportunity is how can we live our
lives in such a way that our brand's
message, the message that we would
like to get across to other
people is unmistakable,
that it is transmitted so clearly
that other people cannot miss it.
Let's talk about a few ways.
One of them that I think is
especially important is the idea
of connecting with other people
because your brand never
happens in isolation.
Ronald Burt is a Sociologist
at the University of Chicago
and he has studied what
is called network theory.
And this is basically how do
you make yourself indispensable
in a network.
And what he discovered, and I
think this is quite important,
is that the best way to make
yourself indispensable is
to become the red dot
in the middle rather
than a blue dot on the periphery.
And what this means basically
is that he discovered
in every organization, literally, no
matter how hard they try to root it
out in every organization it's
human nature that siloes are going
to appear, certain people who
should be talking are not talking,
certain departments that
should be talking, not talking.
Field offices and headquarters,
not talking.
But if you, if you can be the
bridge to build those connections.
Now another key piece,
especially in the internet era,
is sharing your knowledge
with other people.
You can have the best
ideas in the world,
but if other people don't know you
have them then it's the ultimate
tree falling in the forest, right?
You're not going to
get credit for it
if other people don't know
it or haven't heard them.
So how can you begin to get them
out of your brain and into a place
where other people can
actually be helped by them?
Well, that is one of the
things that I learned
when I interviewed this gentleman,
his name is Robert Scoble,
and he is well-known in
the technology space,
he's sort of an influencer
in the startup world.
and he told me a life
FAQ you could say to use
in Silicon Valley terminology,
a life FAQ that I think
might be useful
at least metaphorically
for all of us.
Robert gets literally hundreds
and hundreds of e-mails a day,
sometimes close to a
thousand e-mails a day,
more than any human
being could respond to.
And a lot of them are
pretty similar,
a lot of times people are asking
him questions and they want
to know advice about
different aspects of startups.
And so what he started doing,
because he realized he couldn't
possibly respond individually
to all these people, he
started e-mailing them back
and he told them I would be glad
to answer your question,
but not on e-mail.
And what he told them instead is he
asked them to post their question
on QUORA, which some of you guys
may have heard of, it's a question
and answer website, spelled QUORA.
People post questions online and
then other people answer them.
And he said if you post your
question I will answer it there.
And the reason, he told me,
is that if he e-mails one person
back he's helped one person,
it's great but it's not
scalable, it's not sustainable,
but if he answers the question
online with that one action,
that same action, he's
able to help five people
or 50 people or 500 people.
We all have the same
24 hours in a day,
we all are being pulled
in a million directions.
If we can begin to ask ourselves
how can we leverage our knowledge
further to share it with more
people, to make it accessible
and helpful to more people,
that's where we can begin
to have more of an impact.
And over time people begin
to recognize the value
of your insights, they begin to
read those answers and say, wow,
that makes a lot of sense,
I like the way she thinks.
It doesn't have to be
posting them on QUORA,
it could be an internal social
network in your company or maybe you
like the logging or maybe
you like giving speeches
or maybe it's just speaking
out more in company meetings
so that other people hear
what's on your mind rather
than keeping it buttoned up.
But he more we can begin
to share our ideas,
the more other people can benefit.
When it comes to living your brand
I wanted to make sure to conclude
by talking about something
important, which is the question
of conformity versus authenticity.
Now it's pretty clear from our
history culturally that we used
to live in a world where
conformity was really what mattered.
Did you dress like other people?
You have the same credentials
as other people?
There was one right path
and you needed to adhere
to that right path
in order to succeed.
But in the past 20 or so years in
a lot of ways things have changed.
Some, you might argue,
are negative changes.
You might say, well, there's more
job insecurity or people have
to carve their own
paths more these days.
People aren't working for the
same company their whole lives,
there's more uncertainty.
But, of course, as
with Libby Wagner,
where your weakness may actually
be a strength, there's another side
to it, there's a lot more
opportunity for change,
for growth, for innovation.
But there's also something
powerful that's emerged,
which is that in a world where
there's an infinitude of choices,
of information, of resources, of
people competing for the same jobs,
I can tell you what
has become a commodity.
What has become a commodity
is yes men.
is people who think the same,
do the same things, and
contribute more of the same
because there's plenty of that.
In order to be successful
today what companies need,
what the world needs, is different
thinking, people who can see
around corners, people
who can see what's next.
People who like Rose Schuman can
make connections between things
that may not have been
brought together before,
but when you finally see it
it makes sense and it opens
up a new way of doing business.
People who can tap
into new audiences
and new constituencies
and new ways of being.
That is what is in short supply,
and if we can be the person
that contributes that, that
makes us indispensable.
There's some research that was done
by the Center for Talent Innovation
in New York City, and it is
kind of fascinating actually.
And I especially wanted
to throw this in here
because this section is
cosponsored by The Library
of Congress LGBT organization,
but I think that it
actually applies to everyone.
What they discovered,
interestingly enough,
when they did a large-scale
study is that it turns out,
they surveyed LGBT employees and
they asked them do you feel isolated
at work, do you feel
stalled in your career?
And you might think that openly gay
employees would maybe be feeling the
brunt of this, that
they had taken a risk,
that they might be
paying a penalty for it.
I mean, after all, that's why
people stay in the closet, right,
is because they feel that there's
a risk and a penalty to being out.
It turns out, ironically, that
out employees were far happier
and more successful than
their closeted brethren.
Now I'm putting a big
asterisk on this because,
of course unfortunately, we
still live in a country in which
in many states people can still
be fired legally for being out.
But in situations where that
is not the case, where state
or a company has an
antidiscrimination policy,
these are pretty stark numbers.
If you are out you
are less isolated.
If you are out you are more likely
to be successful in your career.
Why? How could that be?
Well, it turns out that
what they discovered is
that when people are holding
back a fundamental element
of who they are it occupies so much
of their psyche it's actually harder
for them to concentrate on
other elements of their job,
like building positive, open
connections with their coworkers.
People feel like they don't
really fully know you,
there's a little bit of a distance.
And so it's harder to
connect and break through.
Now that's a piece
about LGBT employees,
but let me tell you how
it applies to everyone.
Deloitte University and
the Leadership Center
for Inclusion did an
interesting study along
with Professor Kenji Yoshino
of New York University,
and it's on a subject
called covering.
This is based on work that
originated in the 1950s
with a famous Sociologist
named Erving Goffman,
and they've expanded
it and updated it.
And basically what covering is
if you think about the LGBT case,
when you're closeted you are
totally saying, you know,
you're totally not telling
anyone about your identity,
but covering would be maybe
a less extreme example.
People might know that you're gay,
but you are minimizing their
exposure to that identity,
so maybe everybody else has
a picture of their partner
on their desk but you don't
or everybody else talks
about what they did with
their spouse over the weekend
and you don't, you say I and not we
or whatever it is,
that would be covering.
But that's not just a gay thing.
What the Deloitte and NYU
research discovered is
that in the modern workplace
almost everyone covers
in one way or another.
They found examples of
African-American or Latino employees
that felt a need to play
down their cultural identity
in order to fit in.
They found examples of women
who were just a little careful
about talking about their
families or their kids at work
because they worried they
might not be perceived
as a really serious worker if
they were also seen as a mom.
And perhaps shockingly but
not really if you think
about it the study showed
that 46% of white men,
46% of straight white men reported
covering in one fashion or another.
When I first gave a talk, in
fact, about this a gentleman came
up to me afterwards and he said
what you talked about, that's me.
He said about 10 years
ago I got divorced
and I became a single father
responsible for my kids,
I never told my coworkers because
I didn't want them to think
that I would be distracted.
It could be health issues, it
could be mental health issues,
it could be almost anything, but
in our workforce even though we are
in an era now where what we need
more than ever is difference
and individuality and being real too
often we find ourselves in a place
where we're just a little bit
hesitant to go that final mile
and really be that real because
we think that we need in some ways
to still hew to that man in
the gray flannel suit ideal.
What the Deloitte and NYU study
revealed is that covering,
no matter who is doing it, if you're
gay, if you're African-American
or Hispanic, if you're a woman,
if you are a straight white man,
when you are covering you
are less effective at work.
You're not able to really
form the relationships,
the honest relationships with
your colleagues that you need
to be successful, you're not really
able to bring your best ideas
to the table because we become so
concerned about managing perceptions
and managing our identity rather
than our jobs and really being able
to be fully present to excel there.
and so what I want to leave you with
is as we think about how to stand
out at work, this process
of understanding what our current
brand is, creating the future vision
that we want and moving
towards that,
and then finally living it out,
every day taking those steps,
we need to not be afraid to
bring our whole selves to work.
the more we do that the more we
empower other people to do it,
and the more we can create the
kind of culture that is beneficial,
not just for us but for
making the entire workplace,
the entire company, the
entire culture better.
What we need more of is
people willing to stand out
and to be authentic, and it
starts with us and the decisions
that we make, that's how
we can stand out at work.
So I'm thrilled to be here,
and I think we have time
for questions - is that true?
For anybody who needs to leave
early I'll just mention if you want
to stay in touch or get a free
resource, a 42-page workbook
that I've developed from
Stand Out you can get it
on my website at dorieclark.com.
But thank you so much, and I'm
going to hand it over to Yvonne
to do questions and we can chit-chat
and bond as much as you'd like.
Thank you very much, everyone.
[ Applause ]
>> Yvonne Dooley: We're
right at one-thirty,
but I'm sure we can take a
few questions if you would
like to stay back and go
ahead and ask Dorie that.
>> Dorie Clark: Thank you.
[ Inaudible ]
Yes, great question.
Thank you.
And it's one that certainly
has been bubbling
up over the last few years
because, you're right,
in many ways it is a
power struggle, right?
Whose brand is more
powerful, the company's brand
or the individual's brand?
And if the individual's brand
is stronger will recruiters come
to them, will they get
offers from other places?
Yes, that's actually true,
the company is correct.
But, that being said, would a star
performer want to work for a company
that deliberately suppressed
them and kept them down?
Probably not.
And so it's kind of a balancing
act, and I think that companies have
to make a decision do they
want to be the kind of entity
that is a strong brand that
only attracts B players,
where they are always
bigger than their employees
and that is how they keep
it, or are they strong enough
and expansive enough that they are
willing to take in a star performer,
an A player that, in fact, could
attract more business to them
because people say, oh, wow, so and
so is on your team, that's amazing,
I want to work with them and so,
therefore, I want to work with you.
I think, I mean it's
a legitimate concern,
if someone really is
a star performer,
if they can literally write their
own ticket could they be poached?
Sure. But I think that we also
need to start thinking, you know,
I mean companies like
sports teams sort of need
to choose their strategy, right?
But I think more and more people
need to adapt to the reality
that Reid Hoffman talked
about in his book,
which actually originally sprung
from an HBR article
called The Alliance.
And the idea is that we need to
become a little bit more comfortable
with the idea that
taking a job may become
in certain circumstances a sort
of tour of duty, like you would do
in the military for instance, you
know, you sign on for two years
or five years or whatever it is
with an understanding that, okay,
it's a fixed period of time,
but can we both benefit
from having you here for five years?
Actually, yes, even if
you leave at the end
of five years it will have been
good for both of us to have
that mutually beneficial
association.
So I think it's a tricky
situation and companies really need
to ask themselves what kind of an
environment they want to create.
So thank you for raising that.
Yes, other thoughts, questions,
stories about standing out?
Yes, sir?
>> So when it comes to standing
out in the workplace how
do you recommend navigating
generational shifts?
Because where you have management
Gen Xers or Baby Boomers it's sort
of that got to work 18 hours
and put everything into it,
where with Millennials it may
be I'm going to work 18 hours
but I may do two hours from a
Starbucks and three from a bar,
and it's not that, you know,
it's just different work habits.
And so how do you advise navigating
that because I see that with a lot
of my friends who are in
that Millennial category?
>> Dorie Clark: Yes, yes, and
questions about flexibility
and telecommuting and
things like that.
I mean you're absolutely right that
for a long time the model has been
that the ability to have
that flexibility is a
privilege, not a right.
You have to ask your employer,
well, can I please on Friday work
from home, or things like
that, and it's something
that you earn over time, et cetera.
And so if people are coming in,
let's say if Millennials are coming
in fresh from college and they
did all their homework assignments
at the Starbucks and, well, why
can't they do it for work, you know,
isn't it about getting it done?
Why does it matter where they were
when they actually accomplished it
or wrote the memo or
whatever they needed to do?
It can create misunderstandings
or different expectations.
I'm a fan, personally, my personal
bias is toward maximal freedom
and flexibility, but as with a lot
of things the progress
comes in fits and starts.
One of the things that I thought
was actually most interesting,
a few years ago when I
was researching Stand Out,
when I was first coming up with what
are the ideas that I wanted to write
about and explore further one of
the things that I actually thought
about including at the time was a
concept, you guys may have heard
about or been familiar
with, pioneered at Best Buy
in Minnesota called ROW,
Results Only Work environment.
This was a very innovative idea much
talked about in management circles
that for several years
was the law of the land
at Best Buy Corporate Headquarters,
which was extreme freedom
and flexibility.
There were no set work hours, you
know, flexible vacation policies,
and it was considered a real model
for an innovative workplace
in the future.
And it operated for a few years
and then they shut it down.
We look at Marissa Mayer, famously,
ending the policies at Yahoo saying,
nope, sorry, you guys
come back on in here.
And so we're still, there's
no cultural consensus,
you see different managers kind
of pulling in different directions
and so there's a lot of tension.
How does this apply to standing out,
how does this apply to
your personal brand?
Well, I would say we, of
course, as individual performers,
if I'm working in a company
you always want to try to be
as keenly attuned as
possible to your boss
and your boss' expectations,
that's just a reality
that you have to deal with.
This is the person who is primarily
responsible for your future at least
in the context of that company.
So to a certain extent they set
the parameters of what you can do.
However, my addendum to that is that
even if you are having to play along
with rules that are not
your preferred rules,
that is why I would encourage
everyone in the workforce
but perhaps particularly
younger workers
to not put all their
eggs in that basket.
If you devote 100% of your
life and your attention
to pleasing your boss that's
great and it works pretty well
if they're always your boss and you
always want to work at that company,
but that may not be what you want.
If I was advising somebody who
is 24 years old I would say plan
for maximal options for yourself
and what gives you options is
building a brand simultaneously
outside your company,
build a network,
join professional associations,
don't just join become an officer
at professional associations,
start to get known, start blogging.
You know, if you're allowed by
your employer start blogging
about your field, create a Twitter
account and start following people
and building discussions and sharing
and curating ideas
about your industry.
The more well-known you are outside
your company the more respect you
get inside your company because
they know you have someplace to go
if you ever want to, and that
kind of freedom, you know,
we were talking earlier
about the power balance
of whose brand is bigger,
yours or your company's.
And so if you can maximize your
brand it actually helps your
company, too, I mean
hopefully they see it that way
that the rising brand tide lifts
all boats, but it gives you options
and power if the tide turns
and something bad happens
at your company.
You never want to be in a position
where you do not have a plan B
and a brand, a strong brand always
gives you a plan B. So I want
to be respectful of folks' time.
If people want to come talk to
me afterwards please come on up.
It's wonderful talking with you.
Thank you for your questions
and have a great day.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of The Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.